who are the um
like like is there somebody who kind of
inspires you
in that space to like level up the
hustle to level up like
what you're doing because i feel like
with this music thing there's just a
whole nother stream of revenue that's
about to get knocked down for you
and you've been doing music for a few
years now obviously um but to really
like catch one is like different but
like who's some people
not necessarily just on the youtube side
just in general in the music industry in
the entertainment industry that kind of
inspire your hustle man
i would say i want to be like
like the next five years i want to be
like a ditty
okay you know what i mean i'm trying to
have like you trying to do everything
i'm trying to do everything my own
liquor and
all types of crazy [ __ ] like i'm always
bro i'm doing so much
all 10 fingers touching something yeah
what all you have going on obviously we
know
know about the music we know about your
youtube [ __ ] but like what else do you
have your hands in
you know any only fans pimping i made a
lot of money only fans in a very short
amount of time
i bet you did a lot
but i can't tell you i'll tell you off
camera without it ain't none illegal
okay but i would tell you off camera but
any any sort of crypto
you're [ __ ] with yeah i just ate
because bitcoin just said twenty two
thousand dollars
i ate i'm eating right now i'm still i'm
still in there
do you remember when you bought bitcoin
like how much it was three
years i'm not up up like everybody else
like i should be right because i bought
it when it was fourteen thousand dollars
in like 2017 like a dummy
i didn't know what i was doing but i
lost it all
it went down right but i never never
sold so you said it went all the way
back up
no i'm up you might i think you should
sell now i think it's gonna dip again
so now just rebuy i don't know what do
you think erica rock bitcoin boy
should he sell now that [ __ ] is
gonna hit
30. i'm not giving him financial advice
that's [ __ ] you're over here giving
mushroom advice you [ __ ]
that [ __ ] it's gonna hit like 30. [ __ ]
if it hit
it it's gonna keep going bro it might
we'll see we'll see goddammit